so what do you guys think of the state
of YouTube right now then right in that
guy I'm dumb I'm just jumping right into
it okay I hire prostitutes you're doing
I imagine do you imagine died you don't
have any issues really with YouTube I
know coming out this week about why I
hate Japanese TV and I've got clips from
Japanese TV in it that's the first time
my video could get bug it for years even
get like demonetised few times 1 2 3
years ago yeah oh yeah not recently
maybe for swearing event is flaring
Fukushima documentary got a little bit
buggered for being a sensitive topic
spend like two three weeks on this
amazing documentary that I was really
proud of it and then Lucci was like
night we're not praying that that then
thought no views that's the worst
feeling in the world
yeah I was amazing video by the way I
don't but like luckily loads of people
on Twitter seem to push the video and
then I contact [ __ ] okay and they did
something it kind of released it and
then these started going up and so it's
kind of doing right now
holy [ __ ] actually works watch this the
first story I've ever heard of someone
contacting YouTube especially about like
getting multi monetize or age-restricted
or something I'm getting that it works
and it works
they removed like 200 copyright claims
from my channel twice so that was nice
of them yeah I mean I was surprised I
mean that was a [ __ ] miracle that
yeah yeah my whole channel I was using
an outro song that I bought licensed to
turned out this guy made it didn't have
a license to did so I had a bogus
license and I had like a hundred and
forty videos all my revenue overnight
which got taken and I beat it the first
time because it was being copyright
claimed by him the second time was being
copyright claimed by Warner Brothers Oh
Salman a night was like a nightmare so
had to re-render all my videos out with
a silent thing and YouTube did a thing
where they like swap it with the live
yeah yeah yeah which they never do they
rarely do it and the only reason they
did it was cuz I talked [ __ ] about my
partner manager in one of the videos I
was actually not bad that could have
gone either way that could've been like
yeah [ __ ] you
right at the time I was so frustrated
like my god like I just lost thousands
of dollars yeah every month right sir
but they worked with me and we got it
done but that's the only time I've had
like a positive experience cuz like the
thing about YouTube is that it's just
sometimes it's terrifying just to put
your entire like livelihood on someone
in someone else's shoes or someone
else's hands because I remember the the
biggest heart I've ever got which was
like I think was last year where I
logged onto YouTube and I just had this
message that said your account has been
terminated
they've got to monetize right the whole
channel um did I think I don't know I
got to monetize I remember cuz like mr.
piece yeah that was that one somewhere
everyone involved like I don't think I
could upload anything yeah I don't know
if I've videos or even up like I can't
remember exactly what happened because
it was like a blur because you know when
you read the message when you're riding
out there do you like what do I do like
how did this happen like it's it wasn't
like a copyright claim
it wasn't anything I'd seen before it
was just like it just basically shut
down took everything right yeah I just
took everything and do you know what you
know what sucks is that now to be like
to really get YouTube's attention you
just have to make as much noise as you
can on Twitter which is the key yeah it
sucks though if they don't have a good
support system
you basically have to hope that you can
make enough noise and you have enough of
a following or social media presence on
another platform aside from YouTube to
make enough noise on Twitter um it was
just something wrong their algorithm
that they had mistaken God why do I know
more about this new they mistaking you
because you slob any footage that he was
reusing like content and I think they do
monetize channels that use too much
footage from rows and they mistakes it
fell she not being fair use I think is
what happened or if I'm right I mean I
wouldn't be surprised if that was the
case yeah yeah I don't know why I
remember this so vividly I don't know
what you remember about than me more of
God [ __ ] than him I know his bio yeah it
was just a blur for me cuz it was just
that was the most stressful day because
it was like 24 hours for fix yeah you
know that's fair enough 24 hours but 24
hours just like logically you know mayor
this is probably gonna be fixed you know
that
it'll be fine by tomorrow yeah like us
24 hours oh no it was long 24 hours in
my life because actually it was the
second time that my channel had been
deleted so my the first time my channel
got deleted was in 2011 which is why if
you go to my like oldest video it's from
2011 and that's because I had to reload
everything um and that was you know that
was only back when I had 30,000
subscribers but like I mean at that time
30,000 40 felt like the world no no it
was it was and that was like that was
the most like my heart sank lower then
like anyone had ever like I'd ever felt
before just just seeing years of your
work just be just like go down the drain
and it's completely out of your control
um so that's like the one downside of
being a youtuber the biggest downside I
I'd say for for me sense of it all being
outside your control yeah